welcome to gamespot of Thrones you are
watching it just a mere clip from a much
longer show where myself Kate and Dave
talk about Game of Thrones like the
massive nerds that we are so make sure
to come join us at youtube.com slash
gamespot or at gamespot com or on iTunes
hopefully we'll see you there so our
lovely wildling lover is still alive yay
Kate what did you make of admittedly the
least surprising reveal of all time well
I think it's it's good that it finally
happened I'm glad that it happened
because you know there was so much
tension especially in that last episode
with the wiping and the hair cutting and
you know that scene is only there just
to make you go is this gonna work is it
not going to work you know after all
that we're thinking it's definitely
gonna happen but then it didn't happen
and we were like oh god is I think the
cruelest trick also when ghosts opened
his eyes for Oh No so yeah he's not we
don't think he's walked into ghosts and
if he has then like so what nothing
happened of it so ghost is happy John is
presumably a little happier having been
made alive again Emma poles though mmm
that's true I mean for all the people
who are dead and have been resurrected
he's not the worst looking no he's a
little bit blue he's got some holes here
and there but we actually see in the
preview next week his back still looks
really nice and he's got a nice heck he
has had a nice haircut so what do we
think it's gonna happen to malice and
right now that you know she's lost her
faith but maybe it'll come back she's
brought choked on snow back to life they
called up Joe so Joe snow I don't think
it's the end we've seen of her I know
kind of seems like hope storylines
petered out a little bit yeah but I
think that if I mean like we saw in the
preview for the next week's episode that
they think he's a God reborn and ozora
hi I'd like to think that she kind of
latches onto to that and sort of like
her her misplaced faith in the Lord of
Light kind of you know she she rallies
around John cuz I like her as a
character you know she's always been
just this great staple I think of just
like mystery in Game of Thrones so I
don't want to see you I mean I do think
they left the room
little bit quickly given that she was
you know doing all this stuff maybe it
takes more than like 30 seconds for the
ritual to work just stick around and
they hadn't left the room for ages up
until that point so I didn't why didn't
they just stay there for a bit longer I
don't know but what do we thinks gonna
happen next for off favorite bastard
well now he's you know woken up the
waddling is gonna be like hey man you're
that cool guy and now that we've we've
seen what's happened to Ramsey and we
know what he wants his objective is to
match the wall maybe we're gonna see
some of these characters butt heads
finally yeah it's nice to see different
characters in Game of Thrones you
haven't like we're in season six and
they haven't interacted really at all
it's kind of nice to see sort of just
all these threads and paths crossing and
if anyone's gonna put her on Ramsey yeah
John I can't wait till he gets over the
narrow seam meets dinero so they can
marry and have beautiful Targaryen
babies Ramsey's just like I don't want
to say that he went from nought to 100
cuz he's always been in like 70 but he
went from like 72 like a thousand in
this week's episode he just like this is
the craziest I think I've ever seen him
I love it I love Ramsay's a character no
Dave you've got some opinions about Mad
Dog Ramsey yeah so last week we did
predict quite accurately in fact he
would kill his father based on how much
we see of him in the trailer and you
know Ramsey being mental yeah and then
we didn't quite we didn't quite realize
how he would dispatch his extended
family so we did think that maybe if
lady Walda did give birth to a son and
you would see that as a threat could
drive him to to murder but he kills his
father stabs him you know that's get us
Game of Thrones when I want everyone get
stabbed yeah and then he leads lady
Walda into the kennels and the guise of
taking her to ruse to show him his her
new his new little baby boy but like she
must know the layer of Winterfell why
would she go there it's not it's not how
the realms possibility that she thinks
ruses and the kennels maybe until you
know he starts opening all the cages
yeah this is it's a bit dark but I
it a bit dark a baby cosmina a newborn
baby give me and a life I dogs not a
hospital I don't know if that was a
newborn baby I think that's a bit of a
plot hole that you know they go you've
got a son and then she's just walking
around like normal loving husband
whatever as Ramsey said he prefers to be
an only child mm-hmm and then whistles
sets the sets of hounds I'm really sad
Walder they do older and a named small
newborn what is Rameses obsession with
dogs he isn't that dog mmm he's mad dog
dog no dog mm-hmm doggy dog world
exactly doesn't talk dirty puppy baby
and Doug eat fat woman human why are we
really surprised about randy's actions
is this the worst he's been to be expect
him to do any worse it's not the worst
he's been but newborn baby literally 20
minutes old well maybe it is I be cut
off someone's wiener doing a baby I
guess technically that's worse but he's
always been quite cold and calculated in
a mad kind of way and the tension in
that moment was just awful like he knew
what he was going to do from the minute
he saw lady Walder in the courtyard he
was like come with me into the kennels
whoops wrong place oh no the dogs
escaped oh look you're dead no haha
what's really unsettling as I think like
he did all of this in front of people
yeah the fact that the entirety of all
of his men all of his subjects all of
Winterfell are so scared of him he can
do that blatantly in the open hearing
all the scream seeing his father get
stabbed and nobody even looks twice yeah
he's look that much fear behind him what
was so interesting to me is that ruse I
guess always had this control over him
and it was sort of like ultimately him
legitimizing Ramsay which started his
downfall yeah like I didn't need him
anymore yeah he kept pushing him and he
kept saying things like if you want to
be the Mad Dog if you want to be a
psychopath your ideas to storm Castle
black it's stupid blah blah you played
these games with her you and your games
yeah and like he knows what his son is
like but I guess something must have
blinded him to think the Ramsey would
never turn on him and so when he did I
kind of delicious although it was dark
skip pay back a little bit a little bit
that mad dog line is definitely
foreshadowing if you're gonna act like a
mad dog they'll treat you like a mad dog
and I forget the bit after the accident
write it down but something about
getting killed so basic unless unless
like it's for charting Ramsay's ultimate
end and that the dogs turn on him I
don't know if it's gonna be dogs I think
that would be nice but they're too
well-trained what if ghost kills him Oh
that'd be nice one on one with Jon Snow
and then goes just go to the jugular I'm
actually yeah I'm up for that I want to
take a brief moment to say welcome back
to the Greyjoy's they have been absent
for quite some time and they kind of do
they do play a big role in the books
they have a couple of POV characters and
I thought it was great to sort of
introduce your on and he was introduced
like in the book he's sort of even more
crazy but they gave a really good
introduction and just how warped he is
um k and i have read read the books but
Dave what did you think of the
introduction to your own because you've
this is the first time you've really met
his character yeah so he appears on the
bridge and you can tell after like a
brief conversation he's a little bit you
know not all there let's say and he
keeps referring to himself as i am the
drowned God I am the storm and the whole
part where he was they says he goes mad
in a storm and his crew tie him to the
mast keep him from might hurt himself
and everyone else when he's free cuts
everyone's tongues out yeah the ship's
called silence which is you know how
makes sense yeah and just just the way
he carries himself he seems very cold
mean the Greyjoy's are cold anyway he
seems just completely just not there
when it comes to violence and killing
his brother yeah when we think about the
implications for yarra so we know that
Yara is kind of more you know peaceful
now I guess you sort of realized that
the Greyjoy's don't have a good standing
to get a foothold on the mainland Kate I
think Yara's gonna have a bit of a maybe
a bit of a sansa moment in that she's
saying things and no one's listening to
her and she gets pushed to the back they
underestimate her because she's a woman
that happens a lot in Game of Thrones so
I don't think it's out of the realms of
possibility but
you know I'd like to see her get some
power cuz she's badass and she's great
in the books she's almost as great in
the TV series but I think ultimately
she's she's not going to get listen to
mmm what I thought was quite interesting
so in the books you're on actually ends
up going across to Essos but it looks
like from the trailers it'll actually be
Yara because there's one point where
she's you can see her with a [ __ ] in
volantis cuz she's got like this tattoo
so be quite interesting to see that if
they kind of split those stories a
little bit and just sort of swap the
characters around a bit which I think we
really cool that would be nice although
based on the books I really hope it's
more interesting I hated the Greyjoy
chapters so much I don't know like I
just think it's there an interesting
sort of family they have a very bizarre
dynamic and everyone's just vying for
power all the time and it's just there's
just a little bit different I mean the
moot happening and apparently Theon is
heading back there ya mook could be
between Yara mm-hmm Theon and and you're
on and anyone else he wants to turn up
yeah most a great joys out there that's
the thing i mean like we think we know
the way that it's gonna pan out but as
the show was proven so many times that
we know nothing we know absolutely
nothing
you